successful and pleasant
we're now restoring our relations
which uh
were
not very active during the coronavirus
pandemic
are the leading ministers from your
government have visited russia on your
orders
and now we're having a meeting between
our ministers
of
foreign affairs and defense
in a two plus two format
we're actively cooperating
on international platforms as well
and despite
all the limitations
last year we had an 80 percent growth in
train turnover
so i'm
really happy to see you mr president
and i hope for that so this meeting will
be useful
especially since brazil
is
one of the leading or the leading
trade partner of russia in latin america
so this is a very important meeting
indeed
welcome mr president
very happy and honored
that i have been invited
we feel a solidarity with russia
we have a good prospect for cooperation
in various fields before us
such as
in the fields of defense
oil and gas
agriculture
so we hold meetings
i'm confident
that this visit to moscow
will be a signal to the world that our
bilateral relations
have
a good prospect as well
i'm grateful
to your gesture of
pardoning a brazilian citizen last year
we are ready to cooperate
and
i'd like to express
my confidence that this meeting and this
visit will be very productive
you